Dr. Arnn: We all
have a common problem.
How do you live well?
Our well-being, our happiness,
depends upon how we do that.
And the Nicomachean Ethics
is the first great book
written about that subject.
And, in my belief, the
best book ever written.
Why is ethics important?
Student 1: Because we're trying
to figure out how to be good.
Dr. Arnn: Good is important.
Every action, and every
choice, and every inquiry
we seem to make for some good.
Somebody give a
simple definition
of what it is to be ethical.
Student 2: Ethical would
be to pursue a good life.
Dr. Arnn: And get there, right?
The reason this book is to
be read is to become good.
This is an urgent inquiry.
We are the makers
of our character.
The claim of this book
is that this is certainly
the way to live well.
You can become awesome.
Start today.